hey guys it is Monday my name is Jeff I
used to be behind the camera oh yeah I
know I am we just roll with it yeah fine
[Music]
first up Microsoft has confirmed that
they're not going to insure frame rate
parity between the Xbox one and Project
Scorpio Xbox engineering leave Mike
Ibarra responded to a fan on Twitter to
explain that the choice of frame rate
between the two systems is up to the
developer the fan was concerned the
higher powered console would be held
back if the same frame rate were
required on both systems that said
allowing different frame rates in
multiplayer could present its own set of
problems
Microsoft is positioning Scorpio as the
most powerful console ever made
Microsoft Studios boss Shannon Loftus
also weighed in 20 min thinks developers
will keep the frame rate consistent for
multiplayer games all Xbox one games
will work on project Scorpio and some
will look and perform better similar to
how the ps4 and ps4 pro work Microsoft
is expected to reveal more details about
project Scorpio at e3 this year and the
console is expected to launch this
holiday just what's the most
underrepresented landscaping video games
America it sure is that's why far cry 5
is going to be set there
Ubisoft has released four short teaser
trailers showcasing hope County Montana
each video features a picturesque
landscape interrupted by something
disturbing like this buddy this guy
getting shot in an open field and this
dude literally ringing someone's Bell so
it looks like we're going to be making
wallets stateside perhaps it's some sort
of summer camp gone wild the teasers
finished with the title card confirming
a worldwide reveal is coming this Friday
May 26th if you like me and have a
crippling fear of being left out that's
kind of why I'm on use today hit
subscribe for all of our coverage of the
far cry reveal and III in just over
three weeks far cry 5 will be out
sometime before March 31st 2018 like
everything in life gaming news has its
ups and downs and unfortunately today
I've got a down fear it's like a roller
coaster that's what that was
Red Dead 2 has been delayed until spring
of 2018 originally slated for at least
this full Rockstar have announced that
they've delayed Red Dead Redemption - to
quote ensure we can deliver the best
experience possible
our fans the dev went on to highlight
the fact that Red Dead 2 will be the
first Rockstar game built from the
ground up for this generation of
consoles to make up for the delay though
the announcement was accompanied by a
handful of new screenshots of Red Dead
whose wilderness Smokey bandit and
ornate six-shooters more info will be
shared sometime this summer that is
everything I've got for you today do let
me know down in the comments what you
thought today's story is not equal of
today's show and Jeff I had a great time
great alright real good I'll get the
rock